The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osu.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: All right.
Everyone has their candles lit?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So you can start the quiz.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
AMY BANZAERT: All
right, so time's up
so you can just turn--
hand all the quizzes down
the lanes to get to me.
That would be great.
Given the amount of
background and expertise
you have in this
area, I'm clearly
not going to grade these
quizzes with a lot of cruelty--
so I don't know how
to put it, but they'll
be graded leniently
so don't stress too
much about getting it through.
The real idea was
to call it a quiz so
that you had some
motivation to do the work
and then to
experience doing work
with a variety of
different lighting
situations, all of which are
pretty limited in function
compared to what you're used to.
So we're going to do part
of the lecture in the dark,
so you can keep your
candles and lanterns
and whatever you want
on because that's
all we've got for right now.
I would ask that you don't
use your flashlights too much
because they're really noisy.
So first I just want
to talk about what
it was like to use each of
the different lighting sources
and light to have to do
work, doing all of them--
using them.
We started with
just candle light.
AUDIENCE: Quite difficult.
AMY BANZAERT: So candle
light was quite difficult?
AUDIENCE: Very difficult.
AUDIENCE: There's just one.
AUDIENCE: It's a very
limited light source,
low light distribution,
and [INAUDIBLE]..
It's actually very low
lux so it's inconvenient.
It's definitely a way to
go without electricity.
AUDIENCE: When
your family is sick
and you're huddling
really close together.
AMY BANZAERT: And just make
sure you speak loud enough
so everyone can hear.
When people are sick,
everyone's huddling together.
Yeah.
Curt, did you have a hand up?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
if Carter said this,
but it flickered a lot.
AMY BANZAERT: It
flickered a lot.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When the flame is
more protected, that helped.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
What else about the
second candle helped?
AUDIENCE: The diffuse light.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I like that
it helped diffuse light
and it made it a lot
easier to-- or distribute
the light a little better.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So the second candle has the
diffusing aspect as well as
the wind protection,
both of which
add a lot to their
functionality.
And then next I gave you
guys some aluminum foil.
How did you use it and
did you find it useful?
Let's go to each group.
So how did you
guys use it, Missy?
AUDIENCE: We put it under
our two handles and kind
of just spread out the light
a little bit along the table
so since we were all crouched
over anyway, it really helped.
AMY BANZAERT: It did help?
Yeah.
And how about you guys?
AUDIENCE: We put
it up like this.
AMY BANZAERT: And did
you find it helped?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
And then back there?
AUDIENCE: We reflected it
towards the writing area.
AMY BANZAERT: Cool.
And how about you guys?
AUDIENCE: We did the
same thing, put it over.
AMY BANZAERT: Great.
And you guys actually
started with some tinfoil
that I guess you got from lunch.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: Nice.
Yeah.
And then we added the
flashlights, I think.
Is that right?
And some of you guys used
them and some of you didn't.
So for those who used it,
what was good about it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It was very
bright, very concentrated.
It was nice.
Just the life span
of it was very short,
so it was a lot
of work that need
to be put into it to get the
light that you desire for this.
So short-term, sure,
it's nice use, but--
AMY BANZAERT: But
it's a lot of work.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
So maybe one person would do it
and they'll just write the quiz
and then swap.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, you guys liked it.
Jessica, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have to agree with
what Carter said.
Also when I started
with the candles,
the first one was annoying, the
second one got so much better.
By the time that we had the
lantern that you provided,
the flashlight that you provided
us, plus our three lanterns,
I was like, there's so
much excess light here
we don't need.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So it's kind of phenomenal
how, at this point,
I imagine most of
us are relatively
comfortable in this
level of light.
Whereas if you had
walked into the classroom
in this level of light, you
would not have been thrilled.
But starting with just a candle,
having all these light sources
is actually decent.
However, can you imagine
studying for your final--
during finals week using
this amount of light
to comfortably study?
Would this be-- would
you opt for this?
Probably not.
I sure wouldn't.
I'd want a whole lot more light
to read comfortably and write
comfortably.
Or if you were sewing
or cooking, et cetera.
So this is both a
surprisingly small amount
of light to be highly functional
and yet, very clearly not
enough for really optimal.
For the people who didn't
like the flashlight,
why did you opt not to use it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It was just really
harsh compared to-- the candle
light is a lot softer, and so
when you put the flashlight
on it it was just this harsh
bright light that it was--
it couldn't go everywhere
and at one point
we had some person holding it.
It was just, for lack of a
better word, inconvenient.
AMY BANZAERT: Mhm.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Your
eyes adjusted to it
so that you couldn't
then read anything that
didn't have that light on it.
AMY BANZAERT: Mhm.
So then you were beholden to it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
And how about the back group?
AUDIENCE: Well,
we didn't use it.
I started using it
pointing it papers,
but then my hand kept moving
because I had to squeeze it.
So I think it would be
useful for, I don't know,
like late at night
walking somewhere and just
shining in front of
you where you don't
have to focus it on an area.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But for
the purposes of this,
it was really annoying.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And then your lanterns.
What did you guys notice
about your lanterns?
Any ones that you were
pleasantly surprised
or unpleasantly surprised about
the utility of your lantern?
Oh, a lot of people
notice Carter's reflection
on the ceiling.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Aesthetics.
Just aesthetics.
AUDIENCE: The real purpose.
AUDIENCE: It was better
sideways than straight up.
AMY BANZAERT: And
your original intent
was for it to be straight up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
I mean, this lights around,
but if you're trying to read
you want it--
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
How many of you used
your lanterns in the dark
when you built them?
Cool.
So that's great.
Definitely this is
the kind of thing
where ideally you would
prototype it in the dark
as you were building it.
Any other thoughts
on the lanterns?
OK.
Great.
So I want to just run
through any big questions
you guys had on the quiz.
And I am going to turn on a
bit more light because it's
really hard to lecture.
I learned this the
hard way last year
when I couldn't do
anything trying to lecture,
so I'm going to
get a little more.
Are there any major
questions on the first page?
OK.
And the answers will
be posted on Stellar
so, yeah, you can see them.
What did people get on
the first estimation?
AUDIENCE: What's the--
AUDIENCE: We don't know what--
AUDIENCE: We turned
our quizzes in.
AMY BANZAERT: Say again?
AUDIENCE: Oh, we
turned our quizzes in.
AUDIENCE: What was the question?
AMY BANZAERT: That's
really unhelpful.
I'm sorry.
I didn't think this through.
So the first question is, how
many average incandescent light
bulbs can an average adult
power by pedaling on a bike?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Two.
AUDIENCE: I put two.
AMY BANZAERT: Two, eight.
Anywhere else?
AUDIENCE: I have no idea.
AMY BANZAERT: OK, so
that's about what I got,
so we're all in the same realm.
So 100 to 200 watts pedaling,
which we talked about
in an earlier class, and then--
excuse me.
And then we have 40
to 100 watt bulb.
So dividing that out is anywhere
between one and five bulbs.
Is that vaguely
what you guys did?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: Great.
Can you see this
at all in the back?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: So
you no longer have
to maintain your family bonds
so if you want to move forward
so you can see,
feel free to do so
because I don't know how to--
maybe I can try this headlamp.
Let me try this one first.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And now I feel really
awesome, fashion-wise.
OK.
So second question is, how
long will a solar lantern
last at night turned to its
maximum settings for LEDs?
And so I heard a lot of
questions on this one like,
what is a solar lantern?
I don't have any
context for this.
What are you talking about?
And one of the muddy
cards that I got last week
was, why are we doing all
these ridiculous estimations?
Are you just trying to
make me feel stupid?
And no, I'm really not trying
to make you feel stupid.
And I totally get that when you
get this estimation question
and it's written just the same
way as a normal problem set
problem that is basically like,
how do you integrate x squared?
And you're like, I know
how to do x squared.
I know the exact right answer.
I can do it a hundred times.
And I'm giving you this question
with not enough information,
not enough details.
It's a really different
feeling, and it
can make you feel really
insecure and foolish
and stressed out.
And part of the reason we're
doing this over and over again
in every class is so you
get used to it and you get
acclimated to it so that
immediate stress response--
oh my God, I don't know the
right answer, I'm a moron,
oh my God--
dissipates and is
replaced by, all right.
Well, I don't know off
the top of my head.
Let me think about this.
What are the contexts I can use.
What are those
techniques that we
talked about in the
first day of class that
can help me start to approach
this estimation problem
so that I can come up
with some of answer.
And that I'm going
to be confident
that I'm not going to
get the right answer,
but I'll probably get it in
the right order of magnitude
or in the ballpark,
and that that's
what we're going for here.
So it's to get practice
with doing this
so that you start to feel
more comfortable with it.
It's never going to feel
the same as when I ask you
how to integrate x
squared, because it's
the difference between
rote memorization
slash truly understanding
calculus, and approaching
a brand new problem with
very little information
and very little time and
knowing how to handle it.
But the latter is
really powerful.
Basically anyone can learn
calculus with enough time,
but learning estimation
takes some practice
at a different level
that's really, really
valuable long-term.
So no, I'm not trying to
make you feel stressed.
And the goal is, when
you see this problem,
to spend less time on
what the heck and more
time on the, well, let's
approach it this way.
No, that's not--
that's a dead end.
Let's try this way, this
way, and just get fluid
in those different approaches.
So this question, the
solar lantern lasts,
what did you guys come up with?
How many hours or days
did you come up with?
Yeah, Jessica?
AUDIENCE: I was actually
going to say that I really
like this initiative because,
for example, we already jumped
to some of the
assumptions that we knew,
or calculations from last class.
But we forgot to account for--
for example, we were thinking
of a 3 meters squared panel
and here a lantern is not
going to be 3 meters squared.
So what I'm going to
say is that we supposed
that we're going to have
a storage device that's
going to be 3 meters
squared and then
our lantern is only going to be
the output demand with the four
LEDs.
And in that calculation
we got, like, 3,000 hours.
AMY BANZAERT: OK, so
given your assumptions,
that doesn't sound crazy to me.
But I bet other people didn't
make the same assumption
on the size of your solar panel.
So what were some other
assumptions and answers?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, we
assumed our solar panel
would be a quarter size
of the smaller solar panel
that we used last week.
Then we also assumed
that only 20%
of that solar energy
from the panel
would actually convert into
chemical energy for battery
storage.
And subsequently, when we
calculated everything out,
it was around three hours total.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
Great.
So that's a huge
difference, but there's
some really vividly
different assumptions
that mandate that that's
a reasonable difference.
Do you remember how big the
panel was last week and then
a quart of that so
we can just compare?
AUDIENCE: 17
centimeters squared?
AUDIENCE: Let's see.
It was about a foot squared,
so a quarter of a foot.
AUDIENCE: The calculations that
we didn't have on the board
[INAUDIBLE] were the
previous [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: Did I record
that correctly, Jessica?
That it's 3 meters squared
is what you assumed.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And then what about you guys?
AUDIENCE: We decided that we
would have enough solar panel
to fully charge
an active battery.
So then we just used the
normal battery, which
we set at about 15 kilojoules.
And then charging the
four LEDs for an hour
would use 1.2 kilojoules
and run around 12 hours.
AMY BANZAERT: Cool.
And what about--
I haven't talked
to you guys yet.
What did--
AUDIENCE: So we said insulation
on an average solar panel
is 1 meter squared.
It's 4.6 kilowatt hours per day.
So then-- let's see.
What did I do there?
Then we have
[INAUDIBLE] the wattage
of four bulbs, four LEDs, and
we came out to be 375 hours.
375 hours.
But then take into consideration
20% efficiency all around.
They'll go down to 75
hours of functioning LEDs.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So three of the four groups
were all in the same range,
and then one group assumed
a much bigger solar panel
than is typical
for a solar lantern
but is not untypical for a
lighting system in a house
or not atypical necessarily.
So none of these are out of
control, so that's great.
Are there any other
questions on the quiz?
And I apologize that I
made you hand them back
before I asked you
these questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we found
the measure efficacy
or however you say it
really, really strange.
Is there ever a situation
where that's practically used?
AMY BANZAERT: So lighting
design and measurements
is really, really strange--
in my opinion, not being
a lighting expert--
and it is a very wishy-washy
because of our eyes
and how we basically don't have
a sensor that can use our eyes,
and then there's
so many criteria.
Like have the source,
the light at the source,
and then you have what
it goes through and then
what it reflects off of
and where you're standing.
And if I'm standing
here versus here,
that changes my
experience of that lantern
really drastically where you can
see me much better if I stand
here, but I can't see
you at all because I'm
completely blinded, right?
So no, no.
I do that intentionally.
So that is the
reality of lighting
is it's a really wild thing
to measure and understand
so a lot of the
metrics that people use
are less precise or
comfortable than, say, beam
bending or other things that,
as a mechanical engineer,
I'm a little more used to.
So I'm going to run
through these today
and hopefully
they'll get clearer,
but I can't say that I feel 100%
comfortable on all of these.
And I wouldn't
expect that you are
going to do either at the
end of the class today,
but it's more just to give
you a taste of how lighting
designers think about this.
And if you end up working
on lighting issues,
having the capability to know
where to go to learn more.
But yeah, efficacy.
Yeah.
They're all lux,
lumens, candle power.
It all just is frustrating,
the whole set, which you guys
experienced today, I believe.
Any other questions on the quiz?
OK.
So now what I want
to do is just show
you a bunch of
different light sources.
So you guys can leave
your candles on, but maybe
turn off the flashlights
and lanterns so that--
unless it's really awful
with just the candles.
So to start with, so this
device is called the d.light,
and it's one of the more
well respected lantern
companies out there.
It's quite robust, though
some of our community partners
who use it--
it's far from 100% robust.
It has a bunch of different
brightnesses that you can use.
It has a nice diffuser that
makes it work pretty well.
You saw how well it
worked here compared
to this headlamp gets you
much more directed light,
but that's a lot less
useful for most situations.
So the d.light is
really pretty great.
It comes with a solar panel.
It comes with--
I need two lights now.
It comes with a spot so you
can charge your cell phone off
of the same battery that
you charge the light on.
So it's pretty well respected.
D.light makes
another light that's
smaller that's cheaper
that'll show later on today,
but we don't have a version
of it, unfortunately.
Other lanterns.
So this is made by
free play, which
is a company that
started with radios,
and they also do a lot of
lanterns as well as radios.
And it's a hand-cranked
one, but it's
a little bit nicer than the
hand-crank ones that you got,
or really a lot nicer.
And you can see that the
lantern works relatively well.
There are some things that
you might want to change.
At the break we'll
turn on the lights
and you guys can look through
all of these with full light,
but what I want to do is just
compare the different light
that you get out.
This is a lantern
that I think is Thai
and it has a dimmer and
then a funky diffuser.
And yeah, all of these
I'm just going to show
and we can think about
the pros and cons.
If there's obvious
ones, I'll show you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BANZAERT: What?
AUDIENCE: What's it called?
AMY BANZAERT: I don't
know what it's called.
It's made by Geep, G-E-E-P.
This is the BoGo light,
which is getting distributed
a lot around here.
I'm not sure where
they get their money
but everyone I know who
has one got it for free
at some conference, so
they're distributed a lot.
It has a big solar
panel on the side
and then it has
different levels of LED
lighting that you can use.
It automatically turns
off if it's in the sun.
Some of these do that,
so if it's too light
it won't let you use it
to run down the batteries.
It has a clip so you can hang
it on something on your backpack
or wherever.
Another one that IKEA
makes is kind of neat.
It's a desk lamp and
there's a similar desk lamp
that d.light makes.
The thing that's kind of
interesting about this
is that the solar
panel pops out so you
can leave your light
inside, and then you
can take your solar
panel and put it
outside so that it captures the
sunlight you need to power it.
The drawback is if you lose
that centerpiece, you're stuck.
So there's a pro and con there.
This is a light that takes
a little LED simple--
can you guys see this at all
when I do things like this?
OK.
It takes a little
LED just hand light,
and then it has
an extender for it
so that it diffuses
the light and makes
it useful in other situations
where you don't just
want the task light.
It's a little hard to use.
A lot of lanterns are based
on the classic kerosene
lantern that looks like this.
One is a modified design that--
oof, so bright-- that has
a fluorescent light instead
of using kerosene, but is
still very similar design.
What else do we have?
We have a whole bunch.
I'm going to start getting
just to the ones that
are interesting.
This is one that should remind
you of your solar lantern,
kind of.
Or not solar lantern
but DIY lantern,
because it's very much
DIY and the connection
is a little flaky.
But you can see it has
a built in switch--
sorry for the glare
for some of you.
Maybe I'll point it this way.
It uses a CD as the
reflector, which
works really well
comparatively, and then just
wood for holding the
batteries and a found switch.
Most people in
developing countries,
if they upgrade from
candles, upgrade to kerosene.
So I'm very quickly going
to show you kerosene.
So here's a kerosene lantern.
And what do you notice about it?
AUDIENCE: Smoky.
AMY BANZAERT: So it's
totally smoky, it's smelly.
Kerosene is pretty
dangerous, so it
would be hard to imagine
wanting this in your house,
if you had to, for a
variety of safety reasons,
and certainly carrying
around would be dangerous.
And it has the same flickering
issues that a candle has,
obviously.
So I'm going to blow it out
now so we don't smoke ourselves
out.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it
kerosene power then
or whatever that we use when
we're outside lanterns to keep
the mosquitoes away sometimes?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so that's--
AUDIENCE: You know
what I'm talking about?
Kind of like luau torches.
AUDIENCE: Tiki torches.
AMY BANZAERT: Mhm.
Yeah.
It's the same kerosene.
So that's one of the
things that kerosene offers
is mosquito repelling.
And that's one of the
things to think about
for all of these lights is that
traditional lights do offer
some benefits that people
like, like mosquito repelling,
like heating in some areas.
And just going back to grid
light bulbs for a minute,
we have a setup here.
So watch your eyes.
This is a 40 watt
incandescent light bulb,
which is comically
low in normal housing,
and yet, when we're
used to this low light,
is ridiculously painful.
So then you can add a reflector,
which makes it a little less
miserable to use.
But if you notice just
the color of the light
and then compare it
to this incandescent--
or this fluorescent light, this
isn't the fluorescent light
that's the same color as
these fluorescent bulbs.
They've actually done a lot to
improve fluorescent light color
temperature to make it
more pleasing to the eye,
whereas LED lights are still
quite comparatively blue.
This one has a nice diffuser
so it's less painful.
But you can see how
drastically different the color
of the light is, and
light color really
tends to impact people's
mood and perception of--
AUDIENCE: Life.
AMY BANZAERT: --the life and
how much they like the lighting.
So while LEDs have
a lot of potential,
the color temperature
issue is strong.
The light I was using
earlier, the headlamp,
was really annoying because
it's great for task lighting.
This is a better one, actually.
But it's very-- blind
you really fast, right?
So they invented
this diffuser, which
I think ups the dork
factor an amazing amount.
And there's a reason.
I found this at
IRE on more than--
it was, like, 75% off because
I think no one's buying this.
Because while the idea of a
diffuser makes a lot of sense,
if it doesn't look
good, you're in trouble,
and this really has a lot to
be desired in terms of how good
it looks on.
And that's true
everywhere, that what
a device looks like matters.
OK.
So yeah, so at the break we
can look through all of these.
You can look through all
of these different lanterns
we have.
OK, so I'm going to turn
on the projector now.
About the Kinkajou
projector, which
was actually originally
invented here at MIT in 2009.
So here we-- so that's
the Kinkajou, which,
as I mentioned, is an offshoot.
And you can notice
already how much
brighter this classroom is
just from the little projector.
It's shocking from
our projector,
which is amazingly bright now.
So the Kinkajou
projector, again,
came out of MIT's 2009
class and then went
through a lot of iterations
to where it is now.
So I wanted to show some
of those iterations.
So this was the
initial prototype
that came out of 2009.
I need to pointer or something.
There, and you can see
it being tested here.
And then it went
through two iterations
to where it currently is today.
You might have
heard them mention
that they used
Fisher-Price optics, which
sounds really funny, right?
But toy companies
do an amazing job
of getting costs down really
low and then producing
in high volume.
And so one of the things
that can be really handy
is if you know that
their toy is going
to stay in production
for a long time,
you can harvest those parts.
And that's something D-Lab
Health has been starting to do.
If you know that
something is just
going to be readily available
for the foreseeable future,
why not use those parts?
It's a lot cheaper than
manufacturing yourself or even
buying it yourself sometimes.
So the reason I wanted to show
this is just because I think
a lot of-- one of
the reasons I want
to show this is
because a lot of times
we think about prototypes as
like, oh, we have the prototype
and then we have production.
And instead, in 2009
they probably did
three or four prototypes
to get to this point.
And then this just
shows three prototypes,
and there's actually
many more that they
had to get through
to get to a version
that they could actually
produce in relative quantities.
And this is still in
the order of magnitude
of hundreds of projectors,
not thousands or tens
of thousands or millions.
One aspect of the
Kinkajou projector
that also came up in
2009 in its second year
was, how do you
power the Kinkajou?
And so students worked on this
device, which is basically
a rowing machine, to power the
device, which worked really
well.
Harvard students came up with
a treadle powered device.
And then what they're
using currently
is a battery pack that
connects to a solar panel.
These devices, can you think
why a solar panel might
be chosen over these devices?
AUDIENCE: Way more portable.
AMY BANZAERT: Way more portable.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Minimal work.
AMY BANZAERT: Minimal work.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Noise.
AMY BANZAERT: Noise.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: Timesaver.
AMY BANZAERT: Timesaver.
Yeah.
So the price of these two
sets is relatively similar,
but it's a whole lot easier for
Kinkajou to ship solar panels
than it is to ship
stuff like this.
And then there are
some gender issues
which were addressed
between this and this
in terms of who's
allowed to use the power,
but still, no one wants to
be sitting riding a bike
or doing a rowing machine
while you're in the classroom
if instead you could
have a solar panel.
So while human power is great,
and we talked about that a lot
last time, there's still
opportunity for improvement.
OK.
So this lecture is adapted
from Suzanne Seitinger, who
was in the Smart Cities
part of the Media Lab
and she got her PhD last year.
I'm not sure where she is now.
But she taught this
lecture last year,
so that's where
this is coming from.
So just to give a
little bit of context,
1 and 1/2 billion people don't
have access to electricity.
About a third of the
population in this situation
lives in India, so
that's why a lot
of the projects we're
going to be talking about
are based in India.
Also India has a relatively high
growth that's providing wealth
to a lot of people, and
then still a very second set
of people who are getting
very little benefit.
And so the contrast
means there's
some resources and
some opportunity
there to do work there.
And the International
Energy Agency
doesn't predict this is
going to change very quickly.
So most people are relying on
other fuels, kerosene, dung,
wood, diesel, candles,
battery powered flashlights,
for lighting.
And all of those have
some real drawbacks.
You saw the drawbacks
of kerosene and candles,
at least some of them.
You can imagine the drawback
of battery powered flashlights.
If nothing else, it's just
the cost of those batteries.
Wood is really dirty.
Dung is as dirty as it gets in
terms of indoor air pollution
issues.
And it also interestingly,
just as wood
is bad for the environment, dung
is also bad for the environment
because it's a really
great fertilizer.
And in regions where they use a
lot of dung to do other things,
the quality of the soil
goes down dramatically.
And then diesel, unsurprisingly,
is rather dirty and dangerous,
similar to kerosene.
One other issue that's
really interesting
is how much you pay if you
have modern lighting as opposed
to kerosene.
It gets very
expensive very fast.
So this is just a
set of the range
of how expensive
different lighting is
compared to how light it is.
And this slide is
really hard to parse,
and I added color to it to make
it a little easier to parse.
But basically what it's
showing is how much--
the y-intercept is how
much the initial cost is
and then the slope is what
is the continuing cost.
So ideally you want to be
right down there, right?
So free to start and as low
as possible-- a very low slope
so that the cost of
ownership isn't going up.
So for example, a solar 5 watt
compact fluorescent lantern
is really expensive and it
just keeps going up in cost
because even though you
think it's solar, it's free,
it tends to break a lot, and
so the cost keeps going up
so it's really expensive.
Candles start out free,
but they keep going up.
One thing I found
really interesting
was a simple kerosene lamp has
a pretty nice low slope compared
to most of these technologies.
And then the hurricane
kerosene lamp goes way up,
and I was wondering
what's the difference.
Does anyone have a thought?
AUDIENCE: What is a
hurricane kerosene lamp?
AMY BANZAERT: So a
simple kerosene lamp
is like this one and then
a hurricane kerosene lamp--
it's like the classic
lantern that you
imagine, sort of like this,
but with kerosene in it
instead of--
any thoughts as to what the
difference, the discrepancy is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
glass have to be replaced?
AMY BANZAERT: So that's
one possibility, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it burn brighter?
AMY BANZAERT: I don't
think it burns brighter.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't it
come with something
on the inside that
has to be replaced?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
So both lanterns
have wicks, right?
That's how you get the
kerosene lantern to work.
And a simple kerosene
lamp can use really,
really simple wick
and a hurricane lamp
requires more expensive wick,
and so that's the cost driver.
And it's phenomenal
because you think,
oh, I'd so much prefer
a hurricane lamp
because it's going
to enclose it,
it's going to make it
a little less smoky,
it's going to make the
candles flicker a little less.
But if you have to
use this special wick,
it's going to cost so
much more very quickly.
And then a grid connected
60 watt incandescent
lamp is pretty great.
A compact fluorescent, as
we're all familiar with,
cost a little more initially,
but then your slope improves
and hopefully you make back
your purchase pretty quickly.
So I found this graph to
be really interesting.
When you started
to have questions
about what the
differences are, I put up
the assumptions for that table.
But generally up to 30% of--
yeah, Sanon?
AUDIENCE: I just had
a question about CFM.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when you
talk about the slope
as compared to kerosene,
are you talking about--
like on what basis
are you estimating
the cost of electricity?
Is that the cost in
the US or the cost in--
AMY BANZAERT: So you
can see on here--
I mean, you can't read it right
now because it's too small,
but you can see the assumptions.
So they assumed that grid
electricity in rural areas is
about $0.10 per kilowatt hour.
AUDIENCE: Just kidding,
I couldn't see.
AMY BANZAERT: No, of
course, you can't see that.
That's impossible.
I can barely read it.
So I'm not-- I didn't put this
up so that you could read it,
but that you have
it on your slides
so that you can look
through it later if you
have questions like that.
Yeah.
And I didn't expect
you to be able to read
that whole slide in all of
three seconds or whatever.
So yeah, but I put
that up there so when
you have these
questions of comparison
it's easy to figure out
what the assumptions were.
And these assumptions
are a few years old.
So some of the drawbacks
of solar and LED lighting
are getting better,
but there's still--
I'd still say we're in
relatively the same picture
with some improvement.
So financial costs are a
big issue with lighting.
So people can spend up to
30% of their income on light.
And in this country,
3% is the best estimate
I could come up with.
But it's really, really
high because when
we collect data on what
we spend in the US,
you don't really break it
out-- like you don't break out
utilities and how much
of your electric bill
is light versus how much
is your electric stove
versus your electric
water heater, et cetera.
So 3% is really high.
So people can be spending
up to 10 times more
than we're used
to spending, which
has a huge burden, of course.
Environmental costs are severe
from the proper disposal
of batteries to
wood deforestation.
And then one that we
don't always think about
is light pollution.
So that's less of an issue
in the super rural areas,
but it is affecting
everywhere more and more,
and certainly in this
country light pollution
has a really big impact.
It's great to have light
from a safety perspective,
but then from other
perspectives light pollution
can be really problematic in
terms of pleasure at night
from being able
to enjoy the night
sky, being able to have
a darkened room at night,
et cetera.
Social costs of
not having light.
So everything becomes
difficult at night,
as I think became
clear just now.
So people who
don't have light go
to bed really early compared
to people who do have light.
There's some agricultural
work and other type of work
that need to happen
at night, either
because they have peak
periods where like
if you don't fish in these--
this one month you want to fish
as much as humanly possible,
and if you can't fish at
night you lose a ton of money,
to things like people
collecting rose petals.
That has to be done at night
because once the sun comes up,
the flowers start
to wilt. It means
you just have less
time in your day
because you only have
the time of the sun.
It disrupts education if you
can't do any night school.
You can imagine
how challenging it
is to do surgery
with no light and get
medical care in no light.
And so if you have
any problems when
the sun isn't up medically,
that can be really dangerous.
Then of course, just
security issues.
It's well understood that having
lighting helps with security.
In terms of health costs,
breathing kerosene fumes
and other smoke in
indoor places is awful,
including the particulate
method emissions.
There's just the
danger of fire started
when you have a fire lit.
That's why I actually
included the candle
holders for the first candle,
is it gets-- those candles get
really hot and I didn't
want anyone to get burned.
And then just eyestrain
makes your days harder.
So I think now is a good
time to take a break
and then after the
break, we'll talk
about all those different
measurements of lux
and lumens and all
that good stuff.
So as I mentioned earlier,
it's a dynamic process.
It's contingent on
a lot of variables,
like what are the
requirements of the task.
You can imagine that reading
is a very different task
than cooking in terms of what
lighting requirements you need,
but both you need significant
amounts of light to do well.
Mood and atmosphere
are important,
the appearance, the aesthetics,
the visual comfort related,
health, safety, well being,
the social communication
aspect of lighting, the
different people's point
of view, costs and
environmental concerns.
So there's a lot to consider.
And some specifics.
So brightness is
both the intensity
and the amount of light.
And you can see the extremes
of staring at the sun,
thankfully through a
camera lens, and how bright
that is versus the glows.
And this is not coming
out that well so I'm
going to turn down the
lights a little bit.
Does that look a little better?
Or the same?
I can't tell.
It looks a little
better to my eye.
So the glow, and then
glare is an issue
that you guys all
experienced, I think,
today of getting shined
at by one of my lights
or one of your
lights in your face
and you really can't see a thing
except for the light that's
blinding your eyes.
So I won't glare--
blind you right now.
Contrast is another
thing to consider.
So something with
very positive contrast
where the object is
brighter than the background
as opposed to the reverse
where all you can see
is the silhouette
because the background is
brighter than the foreground.
And again, obviously
if there's no contrast
you can't see anything.
And then one thing
to think about
is illusions associated
with contrast.
So you've probably
seen this before,
but this color gray and this
color gray are the same color
and it's just the
black versus the white
that changes your
perception of gray.
You can click here in the slides
to go see a cool animation
where they actually move the
gray off and on so you can
literally watch
the contrast happen
and the perceived
change in the gray color
happen right before your eyes.
It's kind of cool.
And that's called
White's illusion.
You guys all experienced candles
in terms of contrast issues.
And you'll notice,
obviously I'm not going to--
I could light a candle
right now, so why don't I?
When it was pitch dark,
the candle was really,
really evident and useful.
And now it's kind of bright,
but it's not as shocking
or as useful as it was.
And then another thing to
notice in this picture--
and because it's a painting
it's a whole lot easier to get
the contrast than if it
were a camera, which is why
it's a nice picture to use--
is that this candlelight
works pretty well
for lighting her face,
but it's probably
pretty terrible for
lighting her way in terms
of not tripping on anything.
And so candles have some
aspects that they work really
well on and others not so much.
The color temperature
issue that we talked about.
So I think this will
be less painful now.
Still a little painful,
but not as bad.
So the extremes.
And you can see the candle color
temperature versus incandescent
versus fluorescent versus
like improved fluorescent
versus a more traditional
fluorescent versus the LED.
It's a huge range.
And even if we had no lighting
and just were using the sun,
the difference between
sunlight and shade
is pretty significant.
So we're used to some
range, so expecting
that there's some perfect
color that is the one we're
shooting for is not necessary.
But candles certainly are on
the far end of the spectrum.
And LEDs aren't shown here,
but are on the opposite end
and pretty unpleasant.
AUDIENCE: What's
the unit of measure?
Is that correct?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
so that's Kelvin,
so it's a heat temperature.
Measuring all of
these-- you can read up
on all the different
ways that people
measure this sort of
thing and the controversy
over the different measurements.
Again, because
it's so subjective
it's really hard to get a really
analytical measurement that
captures all aspects
of light performance.
So speaking of that, just
going through the terms.
So the lumen-- and I find this
diagram to be really helpful--
is the light that's
being emitted.
And then the luminous
intensity or candela
is the lumens per angle.
And then illuminance or lux is
the lumens per square meter.
And then luminance is
the luminous intensity
that reaches the eye.
Is everyone totally
clear on that?
Yeah.
So yeah, all the words
are somewhat similar
and we're just talking
about different ways
of looking at it.
And because you can only ever
see the light using your eye,
unless you have a light meter--
which we'll be getting but
we don't have right now--
it's difficult to even conceive
of exactly what these mean
apart from just hypothetically.
And then, of course, brightness
is subjective and not something
that's really easy to measure.
You guys look confused.
Do you look confused--
AUDIENCE: Well, I feel
like when I think of flux
I think of something
going over a certain are.
But it's just [INAUDIBLE].
So I understand lumen as an
energy and the amount of light
that's emitted,
but not as a flux.
I feel like luminous flux
would be more of a candela.
AMY BANZAERT: So
I understand what
you're saying, that
the way flux is
used in this set of definitions
is contrary to the way you're
used to seeing flux.
And I cannot take credit
for these definitions so I
can't help you
resolve that conflict,
only to agree with
that it is confusing.
AUDIENCE: Does that
illuminance versus luminance?
AMY BANZAERT: You got it.
AUDIENCE: What's a steradian?
AMY BANZAERT: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: It says under luminous
intensity, candela or luminance
per steradian.
AMY BANZAERT: Per radian?
Steradian.
So a steradian is, again, a
strange measure of an angle.
I'm not going to ask you
to derive or calculate
luminous intensity,
just so that you're
familiar with these existence.
Yeah, Sanon?
AUDIENCE: No, I think the
steradian is a solid angle,
right?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No, I was just going to
ask the same question.
AUDIENCE: What is it?
AUDIENCE: Steradian's the
measure of a solid angle.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: It's like if you
have a circle you already
have a radian, which means it's
just mapping that to a sphere.
So it's the same
idea as a radian,
except it's a
radian for a sphere.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That makes sense.
Thanks a lot.
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
And so here are a bunch of these
quantities with symbols and SI
units, some of which
help and some of which
add to the confusion.
Like the difference
between light incident
on a surface versus light
emitted from a surface,
it all gets complicated.
And so basically, the
takeaway from this
is that if you want to actually
compare two lights and say,
this one is superior to
that one, it's a lot of work
and it's subjective.
Even with hypothetically
some of these objective
measures it's
challenging because
of the nature of our eyes.
Just like odor is
challenging to measure too.
So when you're using a
basic light meter you're
measuring illuminance, which
again, going back here,
is just measuring the light
emitted onto a surface.
So you can compare when
you-- using a light meter,
some of the things
you want to do
are compare vertical surfaces
and horizontal surfaces looking
at where the light source is.
Usually it's very rare in
a room or in a location
that there's only
one light source.
When we all had
just four candles
there were four light sources.
If only one family
had the candle,
it would have been
one light source.
But normally
there's a whole lot.
There's my computer,
there's the projector,
there's the overhead
lights, there would be light
coming in from the
windows of the doors
if I hadn't covered them up.
So you have to consider
all of those, and then
the stray light sources.
And then whether you're
measuring at eye level
and where exactly is eye level.
Are you assuming an average
woman or an average man
or something else.
And then also at the task
surface as opposed to the eye
surface.
All of those are important.
Just to give you a sense of
order of magnitude, of how
bright and how unbright--
yeah, did you have a question?
Eric, did you have a question
or was your hand just moving?
AUDIENCE: What?
I was just moving my hand.
AMY BANZAERT: Sorry.
OK.
So we can range a
whole lot of order
of magnitudes from a
bright star at night,
which is still pretty dim.
But if you've ever been
in the middle of nowhere
in the middle of the
night, it's amazing
how bright stars
can be on a moon
with-- in a night with no moon.
It's surprisingly bright
once your eyes adapt.
To how strong a moon is to a
living room, hallway toilet
versus living room.
This really depends on how well
your toilet and your living
room are lit compared
to each other.
There's a lot of variation here.
So this is general
metrics, but there's
a lot of variation, of course.
And then sunrise
or sunset is going
to be much brighter
than your living room.
And then going all the
way to full daylight
and then direct sunlight is
incredibly bright and piercing.
So if you think about
sitting on a beach
with no clouds, just
how bright that is,
it's shockingly bright.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How does an
overcast day have more lux
than a sunrise or a sunset?
AMY BANZAERT: What do you think?
Does anyone have a
hypothesis for why
an overcast day has more
lux than sunrise or sunset?
AUDIENCE: I guess the overcast
day has clouds as a diffuser
and then for a sunrise and
sunset it's not direct sun,
but more of the--
I don't know which word to use.
Non-direct.
AMY BANZAERT: Right.
But it's very indirect
and the angle of the sun
is much lower on the
horizon, so the percentage
of the sun that's actually--
the rays that are actually
providing light to you
is significantly lower.
And there's a lot
more diffusion.
Yeah.
So there's recommendations for
task lighting, again, in lux,
so we can use the light meter.
And you can see that
they're typically
measured in horizontal as
well as vertical luminance
and that a kitchen,
reading, desk
work all require a
certain level much,
much higher than if you're
just doing general tasks.
And you saw that today
that we could get away
with a ridiculously low level
of lux in this room and function
when we just had candles
and maybe a little bit more.
But if you wanted to be
really reading or studying
comfortably, you wanted
tremendous amount more lux.
AUDIENCE: What do they
mean by circulation?
Just that going about
your daily activities.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
Vertical luminance would be from
the top to the bottom, right?
Not like going down vertically.
AMY BANZAERT: So they're
talking about measuring it
on a horizontal surface
and a vertical surface.
AUDIENCE: OK, so incident
on a vertical and incident
on a horizontal surface.
AMY BANZAERT: And
then also outside we
have to worry about a
lot of different ranges.
And you can see that you care
a whole lot more about lighting
a monument if you care about
everyone seeing the monument
then you do, say,
in your garden.
It can be a whole lot dimmer and
people can still walk around.
And again, when I was talking
about all the different areas
that you have to worry
about, you have glare.
This is the point of interest.
You have light
pollution that's going
to affect your measurements.
You have some
reflective surfaces.
All of these different areas
are things to consider.
This is one way of looking at
it with a physical diagram,
and this is another one that
runs through the different ways
that you can measure these
different light issues.
OK, so I've gotten through
all these different basics
on how to measure light
and these basic criteria.
There's a whole lot more
content that we could go through
that I'm not an expert in
and I don't think is crucial.
But if you do get
into this area,
it's deep and interesting.
So again, we talked
about just the quality
of the light of
a hurricane lamp,
say, lit by kerosene
versus an LED light.
The experience is
very, very different
both in terms of the
experience of how bright it
is, the color of the light,
the cleanliness, the cost.
All of these things
are quite distinct.
And this graph or
this chart really
tries to document
those differences.
So the brightness is
pretty severely different.
A fuel based light is
much, much less bright
typically than electrical light.
The quality is much
poorer, which you guys
saw, and then the reliability--
well, either one can
be unreliable, right?
And you have to define what
you mean by reliability,
what's more important to you.
Relying on the grid is
great until the grid
becomes so unreliable that
you stop relying on it.
Which has happened
to my neighbors,
for example, when
NSTAR was really
misbehaving a few years ago.
So it's an issue everywhere
that things that seem reliable
aren't always, and
then you start choosing
different types of reliability.
So now I want to go through
some examples of lighting
and lighting tasks.
So learning is
obviously a huge area
where light provides a
huge benefit to people.
If you can be studying and/or
going to class at night,
that frees up a
tremendous number
of hours in the day
that you can work.
And similarly working.
So I mentioned people
plucking flowers,
people farming silk from
silkworms, and people cooking.
All of these things
are really benefited
from being able
to work at night.
These two examples
are from SELCO,
which we'll talk about
later in a few slides.
Markets and vendors.
So if you can sell at
night as well as the day,
that opens up a lot
of potential profit
and potential customers for you.
And then we talked a little
bit about medical care
and the benefit all the
way from having babies
to emergency surgery where
having light at night
is really crucial.
And then just walking
and being safe at night.
Anywhere from driving
to wandering it's
really handy to have
light, unsurprisingly.
And then if you think about
how much time you spend
at night socializing
and how much
harder that would be if
there was no light to do so
and how much less
time you'd have
for interactions with your
peers and with your friends
and family at night.
So lights like the
street light provides
an opportunity for people to
start all of a sudden meeting
and socializing and/or
working together.
So some examples of light.
So I mentioned
the d.light, and I
think this light has been
upgraded a little bit.
And is now called
the D10 or S10.
Maybe the S10.
But basically it's made by
the same company, d.light,
that makes this light, but
this light is about $60.
Maybe $40 in some places.
And this light they're
selling at around $10,
and so it's a whole
lot more affordable.
It doesn't offer the cell phone
charging and similar aspects,
but they've also worked
a lot about making sure
that it offers a really
good quality light.
Some of the limitations of
this light, for example,
were really clear in
just how glaring it was.
And it's nice to
have light at all,
but glaring light isn't ideal.
And so they've done
a lot with diffusion
to make sure that this
light is pleasant to use.
And this is a nice
side by side picture
of using a kerosene lantern
versus using a d.light.
You can see the difference.
This is much, much brighter
and probably a whole lot more
pleasurable to read by as
long as it's not too glaring.
And they also had
two settings so
that you can save your
batteries if you need to.
Grameen Shakti.
You may have heard
of Grameen Bank,
and Grameen Shakti
is a related program
where they've been providing
solar electrification primarily
for lighting to
many, many homes.
And so they're one
of classic example
of focusing on PV systems
to provide lighting.
SELCO, which I'm going to show
a video on about in a couple
of minutes, is another
example where, as I mentioned,
so they were using
kerosene lamps
to feed silkworms, which
they needed to do at night.
And kerosene lamps, as you
can imagine, are dangerous.
Not only are they smelly
and toxic to people,
but they're killing
off silkworms
because they're toxic
to silkworms too.
And so SELCO is able to develop
a solar lantern system that
became affordable through
some complicated financing
methods, which is--
SELCO does a combination
of technology and financing
that allows people to access
solar lighting that they
couldn't otherwise access and
it has had a lot of benefits.
Similarly, solar
powered headlamps.
The story on this project
is that initially midwives
came to SELCO saying, we really
need solar powered lanterns--
like headlamps,
not just lanterns.
Because if you can imagine,
when you're delivering a baby
you need task lighting
front and center.
And if you have a
lantern behind you
your body is blocking
what you need to see,
and so it becomes
very inefficient.
And you don't want a kerosene
lamp right up and close.
That's just dangerous.
And so SELCO came
up with a headlamp,
but unfortunately, midwives
don't have enough clients
to pay for the headlamp.
So then SELCO looked at, well,
who else needs these headlamps?
And they came up with a headlamp
sharing method so that people--
flower pluckers, construction
workers, rubber tappers,
and midwives could all
share the headlamps
so that everyone could benefit.
So that requires not only some
special financing, but also
some special
community arrangements
so that everyone
is able to share
these headlamps successfully.
But when they're successful,
it helps tremendously
for a lot of different people.
So now I want to
talk about SELCO
or show you a video about SELCO.
The founder is Harish Hande.
And I think the thing that
isn't going to come out
in the video enough is what he
really learned very quickly,
but had to do a lot of work
to figure out how to address,
is that he had people
regularly telling him
that 300 rupees a month is
expensive, but 10 rupees a day
is fine.
And you can do the math
really quickly and see
that those are the same, right?
That 30 times 10 is 300.
So why do you think
one would say that?
AUDIENCE: If you're
paying a sum--
firstly, just psychologically
it seems like more money
because 300 is
much more than 10.
But also because,
I mean, I think
it's hard to-- it's easier
to budget day to day.
It's hard to budget
an entire month.
So it's probably easier to save
10 rupees every day as opposed
to trying to save
300 for a month
because you're unsure
of a lot of variables.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So the budgeting cycle is
actually the huge thing.
That people using kerosene
lanterns would sell during
the day and if they made enough
to buy kerosene at night,
they would and if they
didn't, they wouldn't.
And so that gave them a lot of
flexibility for their budget.
Whereas if you spend 300 rupees
and then you have a bad month,
you're out, and
there's no ability
to optimize that
on a short cycle.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I was
thinking that storing that money
somewhere [INAUDIBLE]
business because you
don't want to have saved
up for a whole month.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] budgeting
as picking general habits.
And now you saved up the
whole month and somebody
steals it or it's lost or burned
up because of the kerosene
or whatever.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So saving is risky
and it's also hard.
If you've never been
brought up to be budgeting--
which is something that if
you live in poverty is not
something that you're really
doing on a month to month
or year to year basis, but
are living day to day--
shifting to that mindset
is very difficult
and it does add an element of
risk if you're saving money.
You have to save it somewhere
that has to be secure,
which is a big assumption.
Any other thoughts?
And this is Harish's quote.
But having talked to
him, my understanding
is that 300 rupees a month is
expensive, but 20 rupees a day
is fine.
So people are really
generally spending much more
to live day to day
than they are if they
could live month to month.
But living month to
month is a barrier
so high that it's completely
insurmountable for people
at a certain level
of poverty and below.
So I'm going to switch again.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Street markets are a crucial
part of Indian commerce.
Street vendors sell
everything from vegetables
to incense to clothing
to handicrafts.
Much of the action takes
place in the hours after dusk.
Normally the vendors
depend on kerosene lamps
to light their wares.
SELCO thought that the street
vendors would be better served
by solar lighting,
but the vendors
were in no position to purchase
PV panels and batteries
for solar lighting.
So SELCO redesigned
the value chain
and created a new class of
vendor, the solar lighting
entrepreneur.
With financing
arranged by SELCO,
solar light entrepreneurs
purchased large arrays
of solar panels
that can be placed
on a roof or even a vacant lot.
Every morning, the
solar entrepreneurs
connect a series of
batteries to their PV panels.
The 12 volt batteries are the
size and heft of car batteries.
The entrepreneurs have a set
list of clients in the market.
Some get just batteries, others
get both battery and lights.
The entrepreneur we
visited, Dada Hayat,
has over 50 clients.
At 4:30 the solar entrepreneur
disconnects the batteries,
loads his motorized rickshaw,
and drives his wares
to the market a few
kilometers away.
He then delivers the
solar powered batteries
to his clients.
For the vendors, the solar
lights prove to be a good deal.
An the evening's
worth of light costs
about 15% less than kerosene
would for the same time period.
The lights have other advantages
over kerosene as well.
They cast a wider arc
of light, don't smell,
and do not pose a fire hazard.
For solar entrepreneurs
such as Dada Hayat,
the lights are also a good deal.
After making his loan payment
and paying off other expenses,
Hayat has enough
left over to live on.
Moreover, he also
has the possibility
of further expanding
his business.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMY BANZAERT: OK.
So I think one of the things
that's amazing about SELCO
is that the idea of someone
basically renting a light
or access to light
every day kind of seems
obvious and simple now in 2020
hindsight, but at the time
is quite radical.
And you can kind of imagine why.
It's impossible
for me to imagine
every day stopping by the
market and renting a light
to use tonight and tomorrow
bring it back and repeating.
That's so contrary
to our societal norm
that it's hard to
wrap your head around.
And so this was a really
different approach
that turned out to be
very, very successful
and is a great example
of an approach.
And why are we talking
about this in energy class?
Well, any solution has
the technology piece,
but it also has
the business piece.
And while we're certainly
not emphasizing the business
piece-- and if you want to,
there's other D-Lab classes
where you can focus on that--
you can't design in
a vacuum assuming
that if the technology is
good enough they will come,
regardless of the financing.
Just as you can't assume there's
a good enough financing model
that's good enough if
the technology isn't.
And if you watch a bunch
of Harish Hande's talking,
he gets to that, that you need
both in order to be successful.
So that wraps up the
lighting lecture that I have.
Are there any
questions on lighting?
So I know you guys are really
interested in the community
partners we'll be working
with and what exactly we'll
be doing.
So I wanted to go through first
what students did last year.
Amit, do you mind bringing
those three products over?
So one team worked with
Blue Energy and Blue
Field, which is on
the Atlantic coast,
where they have a lot of
batteries, these deep cycle
batteries, that need to
be recharged regularly.
And the batteries,
they need to be
recharged with distilled water.
And if you don't
use distilled water
you shorten the life
of the batteries
by a really significant
amount, and these
are very expensive
batteries that make up
a big percentage of the system.
And people are living in
islands and coastal areas
where the only way to get
to buy distilled water
is to travel by boat for a
few hours, which is expensive,
and when there's any sort
of weather, is impossible.
And so people will naturally
just use regular water
rather than distilled water.
And by regular water I generally
mean well water or worst case,
ocean water, which kills the
batteries really quickly.
But there's a
temptation to just--
I know we need to fill
the battery so let
me do it with the
water I have here
if I can't get distilled water.
Distilled water also isn't
free if you're buying it.
And so what they developed
were two different approaches
to a distiller at two different
cost prices or price levels.
So one using acrylic
panels and one just
using clear plastic sheeting.
And then you just put it over
a water source and the water
evaporates in the sun.
And when it evaporates,
all the stuff
that's not just pure water
is left in the pan down here
and everything that is
rolling down the sides
is distilled water
and then it collects.
This isn't a good option
for drinking water, both
because distilled water tastes
awful and isn't as good for you
as water that has
some minerals in it,
and also because it's
a pretty slow process.
But if you only
need a small amount
of water per month for a
battery, this works really well
and can be made pretty much out
of locally available materials
and is pretty simple.
And so that was one project
that the students worked on.
What did they do when
they went to Blue Energy?
We did a charcoal
demonstration for people
so that they could learn
how to make charcoal out
of coconut husks because that
was what was locally available.
That involved going
to a coastal area that
is one of those areas where you
can't get to except for boat
called Kakabila.
So we spent some time
there just learning
what the energy situation was,
helping repair a wind turbine,
and identifying other
projects in Blue Fields
that we could work on, and
this is the project that
ended up getting worked on.
All of these projects are going
to be relatively small compared
to, say, a 2009 project.
The reason for that is twofold.
One is that this class
we pretty much work
on projects for
half the semester as
opposed to the whole semester.
And the other reason
is that I really
want these projects
to get to completion,
so a project that
we can actually
hand off to a community partner
at the end of the semester
and say, here, run
with it, and they
can without it falling
apart and just being like,
oh, it doesn't work.
And a lot of projects,
just naturally in academia,
get to the, it just works well
enough for the presentation
and that's it.
And I want to project that will
work well enough to hand off,
which is a different level.
And so that's why we do
relatively smaller projects,
but we get to into deeper
level of design on them.
So the next one is a bag sealer.
So this is working--
oh, and Blue Energy
is likely a group
we won't be able to
work with this year.
But this group
worked with AsoFenix,
which is a group we likely will
be able to work with this year.
And AsoFenix, one
of their projects
was to make a bag
sealer for orange juice.
So in one of the regions
that AsoFenix works with,
they have a microhydro
system, and they actually
are under utilizing
that electricity
that they're provided.
The electricity
doesn't work year round
because the water
isn't there year round,
but in the rainy season they
have a plethora of electricity.
And they also have a
plethora of oranges,
and the orange growing
season is relatively short.
So you have all these
oranges and you can sell them
for very little
in the marketplace
because all the oranges come
to season at the same time.
And so they're
trying to figure out,
how do we save these
oranges to save some money?
And so they looked into
preserving the juice
and then selling
the juice and being
able to sell that
for longer than
you would be able
to sell the oranges.
And so the key piece
that was missing
was, how do we seal the bags?
And so bag sealing
technology exists,
but having a simple
one that connects
to a microhydroelectric
system that's easy for them
to repair and build in
the field was something
that didn't exist, and so that's
what this group of students
worked on.
And when they were
at AsoFenix, again,
they did charcoal
demonstrations as well as
identifying the
different projects
that they could work on.
In this year's class we're
doing it slightly differently,
that we're going to
pre-talk about the projects
and you're going to work on
them a little bit before you go.
That year they were really just
doing project identification.
This prototype has
already been delivered
to Grupo Phoenix, which is
another one of the groups we're
going to be working with,
so I can't show it apart
from the picture.
But this group
makes solar panels
from cells that are reject
cells that don't meet
the specs for Evergreen Solar.
So Evergreen donates the
cells to a Grupo Phoenix
and they cut them up and
make solar panels with them.
And cutting a solar cell is
really, really difficult.
And in the field or in the lab
you would do it with a laser,
but a laser is well
beyond the capability
of Grupo Phoenix, which is
off the grid, pretty much.
And so this group developed
a fixture for a dremel
to allow a more
repeatable process
for cutting the cells so that
the loss rate went from, like,
80% to 50%.
So a big improvement.
Even though 50% is
a painful loss rate,
80% is much more painful.
And then the last group worked
with one organization called
Carré, which, again, we
probably won't work with again--
and also for Grupo
Phoenix, which
we are working with again--
for a stove in a stove design.
We introduced the charcoal idea
to Grupo Phoenix, women there.
Grupo Phoenix is
a neat community
that has a very strong
organization of women,
almost entirely,
and those women are
really interested in
alternative energy.
And so they build their
own solar cookers.
The solar cookers
are really expensive
and so that's a
problematic model
from a financial
long-term standpoint.
But from a community
building social standpoint,
it's a really interesting,
very successful model.
And so we're interested
in working on them
to figure out what are some
other opportunities they can
look into that might be
more sustainable long term,
and one of them is charcoal.
And they're really
interested in charcoal,
but they all use
adobe stoves meant
for wood, which aren't
appropriate for charcoal.
And so I and the students
working on this project
came up with the idea to
develop a stove in a stove.
So a charcoal stove that would
pop into your adobe stove,
wouldn't interrupt your
cooking, but would allow you
to use charcoal very easily.
And the students
came up with the idea
of making sure the stove is
something that could be built
by the women at Grupo Phoenix.
So what they came
up with was a stove
that can be made from a
single piece of sheet metal
with just a couple of cuts
and then a bunch of bending.
And so they figured out the
stove idea over spring break,
and then in the summer
one of the students
went back and introduced the
stove, taught a workshop on how
to make that, and tested
it with some women
to see how it worked, which
is a pretty cool project.
And so that's the
stove right here.
So those are the four projects
that came out last year.
And so this year we
fly into Managua,
which is the capital city, but
we spend almost no time there.
The Grupo Phoenix is in Okatal.
We may work in Jinotega.
And AsoFenix is based
generally in the Boaco region.
So AsoFenix is a
small Nicaraguan
based NGO focused on rural
sustainable development,
and they do a lot
in the energy realm.
They're actually a group that
was spun out of Grupo Phoenix,
so that's why the
names sound so similar.
It's in a very, very
rural area, which
means you have to hike in.
There's no way to even
get a good pickup in.
And so it's pretty rustic
conditions, pit latrines,
bucket showers if
there's enough water,
and sleeping on hammocks.
And one of their big projects
is they have a feed chopper
and they want to be
able to electrify it
because right now
it's human powered
and it's a really, really
manually intensive system
to use it.
And then they also have
interest in biodigesters, maybe
continuing work on the
bag sealing project.
And they're currently
having a meeting this week,
I believe, to talk about
what other projects
they'd be interested in.
That's one.
Second is Grupo Phoenix,
which is in Okatal.
And this is a group that has
a university base in Nicaragua
at the Technical
University in Nicaragua,
and has some connections
back to the D-Lab as well
as other universities.
So it's a little bit more
westernized just a touch,
but it is very integrated into
the community with that women's
cooperative that I mentioned.
And so they're really
focused on trying
to empower the women
to create better energy
solutions for
themselves and preserve
their natural resources.
So this group has
comparative wealth
in that some of the houses
have TVs, things like that.
So some of our
students last year
were surprised by how
wealthy with the people
we're working with.
One of the reasons that these
women are comparatively wealthy
is that this program has
been going on for 20 years
and some of the work
has allowed them
to gain a little bit of wealth.
But the neat thing about them is
that they serve as figureheads
for the whole region.
And so success that they
have gets other people really
interested, and so it's a really
neat program to work with.
Some of the projects they are
interested in-- but again,
pit latrines, bucket
showers is the standard.
But you do get a bed as
opposed to a hammock,
so it's a little
bit more refined.
Is refining their solar
cooker, ideally refining
it significantly to
make it much more
affordable, easy to manufacture,
aesthetically pleasing, et
cetera, et cetera,
more functional.
There's actually a group
of Cornell students working
on aspects of that
as well, so it
would be interesting-- it'll
be interesting to figure out
how we intersect.
But they're going to be at
Grupo Phoenix at the same time,
so there would be an
easy way to overlap.
They're also really
interested in charcoal making
and the stove making.
And so working with
them on those aspects,
both from developing
their skills
in making charcoal as well
as business plan development.
And then they're really
interested in figuring out
a good way to make cell
phone chargers because that's
a huge--
solar cell phone
chargers because that's
a huge need in the area where
almost everyone has cell phones
and very few people
have electricity,
so charging their cell
phones is really difficult.
Other possibilities that
we're looking into right
now are collaborating
with D-Lab Health
because D-Lab Health has
a lot of other projects
and they also go to Nicaragua
and so it seems natural
that we could collaborate.
And they often have energy
needs for their solutions,
and so it seems like
a natural overlap.
So I'm talking to them, but
José, who teaches the class,
just got back from Nicaragua
yesterday so I haven't been
able to talk to
him about that yet.
And then I visited
Jinotega this summer,
which is another
region, and they're
really interested
in making charcoal
from these invasive
lilies in their lake.
And so that's
another possibility.
But I don't have
strong enough contacts
to be able to be sure that
that's going to happen,
but it is a possibility
that I'm working on.
Are there any questions
about all of these?
OK.
So by Friday, I will
have a survey online
so that you can list
your project preferences.
And I know these are
relatively vague,
but that's the
nature of this work.
And then I'll need you to
complete that by Monday.
Even if you're not
going on the trip
I need your preference
because you're
going to be working
on the project
apart from going on the trip.
And then we'll have the
teams formed by the 23rd.
And then from there you'll
be assigned a project mentor
and you guys will be
working in your teams
to work on developing initial
information, information
gathering, initial
prototypes, that you can bring
to Nicaragua to help you have
more informed conversations
with your community partners
and make a better end
product in the end.
The other aspect of work that
may be happening in Nicaragua
in addition to gathering
information about your project,
so get getting feedback on
your initial prototypes,
your initial
approaches, is trying
to transfer some
of our technologies
to the community partners
we're working with.
So for example, Grupo Phoenix
is really interested in doing
some more charcoal burns.
So we'll do that
at Grupo Phoenix
and you'll be trained
on charcoal burns right
before we go, because we
try to push that as late as
possible so that we're
not doing it in the snow.
I haven't had a chance
to talk to AsoFenix
if they want to do
charcoal burns again
or if there's some other
technology they want.
The primary work will be
fleshing out the projects
and getting project
feedback, but there may also
be some tech transfer,
but not a ton.
So does that answer everyone's
questions about all of this?
Because there were a
lot on the muddy cards
so I just want to make
sure that's clearer.
OK.
Cool.
So now I want to go through
the muddy cards again,
which I try to do every week.
One person asked, what is
the average daily energy
consumption for Americans?
Which hopefully you're
intuiting at this point.
I showed it on the
first week slides.
It's relatively easy to look up.
But the average American uses
about 14,000 kilowatt hours
per year of electricity.
So that's not all energy
that we consume, obviously,
but it gives you a baseline.
Someone was confused about how
megajoules and kilowatt hours
are related.
So they're both units of
energy and it's 3.6 megajoules
is 1 kilowatt hour.
And generally power and
energy intuition is muddy,
so can you guys remind
me, energy is equivalent--
can you do a quick
definition of the difference
between energy or
power or a metaphor
or however you
want to define it,
but how are you guys
keeping it in your mind?
Or it's muddy for everyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Power is like velocity
and energy is like distance.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
And energy is
proportional to distance.
So power has-- you're
considering time and energy,
you're just considering the net.
And yeah, if this is
feeling uncomfortable,
I would practice it
for the first quiz
so you get that into your head.
And come talk to Amit
or myself if you want
to spend some more time on it.
AUDIENCE: The quiz is next week?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so I'll
talk about that in a minute.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMY BANZAERT: So confused
about the dissipation of energy
in the grid and having
the wrong length of wire.
So basically what we
talked about last week was
that the longer the
wire, the more--
the bigger resistor you have.
And the bigger resistor you
have, the more heat loss
you have.
And the more heat loss you
have, the less energy transfer
you have because more of it is
going into heat and less of it
is getting to your end
source and your end use.
So that was the basic
gist of last time
was that you're never going to
be able to transfer electricity
perfectly from one
system to another
because there's always going
to be efficiency losses.
But the farther distance
you have to travel,
the more loss you're
going to have.
And so you need to either
minimize the distance
or minimize the resistance
associated with a wire in order
to have a successful transfer.
I hope that clarifies
it a little bit.
If not, again, come talk to us.
Still a little confused
about batteries.
Again, talk to us because that's
too general a question for me
to know what to answer,
but hopefully we
can sort it out together.
And then estimations of my
daily energy consumption
would be easier with
given values of wattage
for common appliances.
Yup.
Sorry.
So the whole idea for this
was to practice the estimation
and then use those
estimates to do
your first pass of your
daily energy consumption,
but then have the
time on the homework
to refine those estimates
with actual real numbers.
But the intent is to
practice those estimations,
so that's why I didn't
just give them to you.
And then one last question
was the source differences
between--
we talked about the
load differences,
but we didn't talk
about the sources.
And so we were doing
a black box source,
and so we'll talk about solar
power in more detail and wind
power in more detail coming up.
But yeah, right now
we're thinking about it
as a black box, so that's
why it's muddy because I
haven't made it less muddy yet.
OK.
Are there any questions
about all of that?
So one thing I wanted
to mention just
to finish up on the Q
Drum, because I didn't want
to talk about it too much
until you guys did all
your readings and stuff, is
some of the criticisms of the Q
Drum.
And I also show the
Hippo Roller just
so you see a different version
but a similar approach.
So what do you think some of
the criticisms of the Q Drum
might be?
AUDIENCE: Leaks.
AMY BANZAERT: It leaks.
Yeah.
So once it starts leaking,
it's a pretty crummy technology
to have.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So on terrain like
is shown by that boy
it's pretty
manageable, but stairs
were sort of an extreme
version of terrain.
But you can imagine
in super steep areas
it's not so fun to use.
So terrain is one concern.
The longevity, the leaking.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I mean, the
water could get dirty
because of where the valve is--
or where the cap is.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So that's a really
big issue on a Q Drum
because you have your valve
right at the edge of the drum.
And so your valve is rolling
in the mud, basically.
And so every time
you open and close
the drum you're getting
dirt into the drum,
which makes it dirtier.
Someone in this
classroom told me
that the Hippo Roller now
has a UV light inside it
to try to address that issue.
They also have their valve a
whole lot higher up in terms
of water cleanliness issues.
So that is one of the
limitations of the Q Drum
is just how dirty your water
has the potential to get.
And it's pretty near
impossible to clean out
a Q Drum successfully because
of the way it's constructed.
Any other thoughts?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It takes
physically more materials
to construct, say, a
five gallon buckets,
and it's not as versatile.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
So a whole lot less versatile
and expensive and prevalent,
right?
Like you can find a
five gallon bucket
everywhere, pretty
much, or the equivalent.
A Q Drum you can
almost find nowhere.
And if you think about
shipping a five gallon bucket,
they stack into
each other so you
can fit a whole lot
more five gallon
buckets in a shipping
container than you can Q Drums.
And that makes the Q Drum
a whole lot more expensive
because shipping costs get
very high very quickly.
Any other thoughts or concerns?
One of the biggest ones when
this technology came out
was they used pictures like
this one to advertise it,
and people were
horrified because kids
were carrying water.
Which is a really
interesting thing
to think about because kids
are already carrying water,
so it's not actually a
very sensible concern
from the approach of
what is really happening.
But from a where are you
getting your money from concern,
it's huge, because if you
alienate all your donors
by showing them an
improved reality but they
aren't aware of the real reality
and you don't educate them
well, you destroy
your donor pool.
And if you're going
off of donations,
which you'd have to do in a Q
Drum because it's so expensive,
that's a real problem.
And so I think that's one of
the most interesting aspects
of the Q Drum for me
is it seems so great.
Kids are dragging water
instead of carrying it,
what a huge improvement.
But if your donors
are assuming now
this is allowing
children to carry
water who used to be in school,
then all of a sudden, no one
will support you.
So it's a really interesting
aspect of this type of work.
And then just to check
in on where we are,
today we did lighting and
community partner introduction.
The lab will be Friday.
Next week will be
solar thermal and PV
and the quiz in the flip
order is what we just decided.
And then-- yeah, this
is where we're at.